[Music]
kids go the future Toombs his friend
would totally say she here but the movie
decides to play its own version of the
pronoun game to hide a future twist
please turn over any and all it no one
saw that not assholes who made this mess
again paid to clean it up
Oh King Woodbine would be excellent at
cinema since I'd say what that's keeping
the world's change it's time we changed
too and like that he's a villain this is
as good a time as any to mention that
the collective timelines of all the
films in the MCU is basically okay I
initially ignored the 35 seconds of to
Sony company logos at the start of the
film but if you're going to prologue and
then give me a 35 second Marvel logo
five minutes into the film and send an
AK twice New York quaint nearly should
the trip you can't show it to anyone
then why is happy letting him film this
at all no what I have to say Peter's
self Ellen captured video journal is way
the do over edited almost like it's a
Marvel film Stark's continued commentary
on Mays attractiveness has now
officially moved from the creepy column
to the offensive column just a stupid
dangerous thing to do in view of all the
schools front windows look at all those
goddamn windows how's your seam ah Jesus
Christ
dear Kevin Feige get your Marisa Tomei
boner and check because it's starting to
creep us all out got to admit I'm not a
fan of the stark Spidey suit spider-man
is cool because he's smart enough to
build a suit himself I don't need
another Iron Man thank you very much
okay I'm not made of steel spider-man
giving directions to an older lady is
exactly what spider-man is all about and
this movie just turned us in off Stan
Lee cameos have become caricatures of
themselves at this point tooms has been
selling this alien tech for the past
eight years and this is the first time
Spidey or anyone else has seen any of it
fine and then is fighting the Avengers
in the bank on 21st Street this is
supposed to be funny and play off of
what spider-man has already set but
clearly this guy I can see from across
the street those aren't the Avengers so
why tell the cops that yeah the craziest
thing just happened to me happy hasn't
answered Peters calls or responded to
any of his texts for the past however
many weeks but conveniently chooses now
to answer one of his calls in Queens
where every other resident is old with
nothing to do but spy on their neighbors
nobody sees this isn't
enough to close this door with his hand
does he need to shoot the web other than
to further sell his in the room right
now best friends reaction Peter just
came in from the window directly behind
net how'd he not see him her sense him
this movie leads you to believe
spider-man doesn't have spidey sense or
doesn't have it yet why is that exactly
what is removing that from the mythos of
this character adding Turkey is a
disaster I could have told you that
before you started cooking but whatever
that's for five how many new backpacks
does he need before Aunt May's starts
asking reasonable questions 10 15 5
clearly doesn't cut it can you spit
fennel can you summon an army of spiders
the series of Ned asking questions to
Peter is hilarious I'll have to yeah we
met but there is zero chance no one
sitting around Peter and Ned can't hear
what they're saying pretty sure this
guy's a war criminal now but whatever
after so DS videos this guy has a point
also public school in a nutshell
everyone okay another sin off this is
funny and all spider-man in the suburbs
but there are a bunch of trees he could
be swinging off right behind him in this
shot alone how did these stupid ass
henchmen think they could demo a blue
alien explosion gun without anyone
taking notice and Peter just happens to
be acting and decisive on the roof to
conveniently see it there's me something
this stick owes somebody I'm not trying
to shoot them back in time look it may
be hard to buy a gun in New York but
it's gotta be easier than getting access
to the only dudes that have this
technology right if childish gambino
just wanted to stick somebody up why not
just go with the finger in your pocket
technique movie steals an outtake from
us
[Music]
somehow Spidey survives this fault even
though later Karen tells him that
falling off the Washington Monument
would be lethal
[Music]
Iron Man X mucking it up to the max iron
max machina he's not what you thought
when I took on Captain America trust me
kid
cap 1 2 lay you out he would have
basically the whole problem with civil
war in one sentence if you come across
these weapons again call happy
considering you never answers the phone
when Peter calls I'm not sure how this
is good advice and how the hell did the
cell phone even survive that thousand
foot fall and submerged in a lake a few
minutes ago didn't get around from me to
the party how is he getting back home
the shocker I shock people
what is this pull Leslie ah damn even
this movie's main villain would be
excellent at cinemasins and if you can
afford me out there though right
everything I'd know not Tom Hardy is not
too bright to be threatening not Birdman
like this yeah that seems smart also
Peter decides to try and get to the
bottom of the whole purple gun thing
mystery during class and somehow doesn't
get discovered these guys would not be
strolling around a 2017 New York high
school during operating hours without
raising some sort of suspicion
Spidey homing bacon kind of lame thanks
Tony Stark for ruining most of what made
spider-man cool the date for the
academic decathlon on this poster says
it's on September 14th however the
poster from earlier in the movie showed
it being from October 13th through the
15th Tony Stark billionaire ingenious
can't create tech a high school
sophomore can hack into detecting 3
individuals giving spider-man his own
Jarvis is yet again and nassima to what
spider-man is all about does it make
sense in this universe with the way
they've you start to introduce Spidey
yes but as much as I enjoyed this movie
I must repeat that I am knocked down
with Iron Man Spidey and yes you comic
fans I know there's an iron spider thing
in the comics I don't care activating
instant kill instant kill
why would Tony even put this setting in
the suit and how does it work exactly
all the sudden his webs become poisonous
possible combinations Jesus
whoops neither do i Peter neither do
want you appear to have a mild
concussion no lie the NFL sued Sony for
this line of dial activating
reconnaissance from spider God spider
God there's literally nothing the suit
can't do for him it's literally not a
spider-man movie unless the girl he
likes ends up in mortal peril literally
this is your chance Peter kisser why in
the ever-loving would Tony Stark write a
suit AI for Peter that gives him a
relationship advice and honestly who
would trust relationship advice from
something written by Tony Stark anyway I
don't see how hang up your mode of
transportation is helpful talk to me
when you're smart enough to suggest this
without being asked stupid suit lady
Karen that's super convenient for Peter
right now also how it doesn't Stark had
access to this footage um that looks
terrible a red and blue paper airplane
would have looked more like a gliding
spider-man than that does hey wait a
second he didn't give any such command
back before casually tossing grenade web
but later he has to say to get that web
site if only there was a large body of
water close by high to throw this in the
spray a bunch of webs and when it
doesn't work use brute strength
sequences way more like the subway scene
in spider-man 2 then I think this
movie's intended Jesus Christ poses
Jesus how the hell did Tony know to
bring these things the ship only split
down the middle like 90 seconds ago does
he just always travel with dozens of
tiny thrust robots everyone okay no
thanks to you there was almost zero
chance no one died in that incident
everyone else said I was crazy to
recruit a fourteen-year-old kid everyone
else was right well this is the fakest
background that ever faked being a
background I guess you already have a
date to homecoming actually I'm so busy
playing and I never really got around to
that part so yeah no that girl has a
date a backup date and three hot
friendzone dudes on standby I know many
of you love this moment and more power
to you but the sheer odds of Peters
nemesis being the dad of his date or
just I mean you could win the lottery
more easily he disappeared like you
always do but you didn't DC to
movie mostly redeems the coincidence dad
thing with the scene where he realizes
who Peter is and which ends with one of
the coolest hero villain conversations
ever I'd kill you and everybody loved
this entire scene have to leave rules
another sin off but also might want to
pull away from the very public place
you're currently in front on before
pulling out that gun gotta go I'm sorry
why does he have to go other than there
wouldn't be a movie if he doesn't the
Saints thing to do here would be to call
happy and let him know you've discovered
the identity of the vulture and he's got
something going down tonight
how did shocker know this was the door
Peter would come out of how the hell did
vulture even have time to call shocker
and get him here to do this Peter went
inside for like 45 seconds shocker must
have been in the trunk of vultures
goddamn car shocker kicks the
web-shooter instead of crushing it or
shocking it I get the spider-man has
insane strength but he doesn't have the
star costume on anymore it's basically
just wearing a hoodie so how has he not
cut up all to hell here and or knocked
unconscious he was knocked unconscious
earlier while in the better suit after
hitting the top of the transport truck I
know when bronzy knows fresh and that
was not fresh this is some weird comic
thing with spider-man and branzino
because in the amazing spider-man the
dialogue makes a point of saying they're
eating branzino at Quinn's house it's
just too fucking weird to be a
coincidence right happy hangs up on Ned
and basically creates the need for this
movie to even have a climax he takes
this call like a normal human being an
Iron Man ends this about three minutes
flat
we just got a load Tony's old Hulk
Buster armor prototype for Cap's new
shield and the making the Magnum floors
magic belt
it's the MacGuffin plane and looking at
porn love Ned why wouldn't Peter just
whip up tombs right now you know how
this wouldn't been an issue if Peter had
webbed up both fucking hands couldn't he
at this point like step forward there's
literally nothing in front of him right
now retro reflective panels engaged
how did Toombs crew know so much about
this moving table and that the plane
will be cloaked just one scene of them
paying off a guy on the inside is all it
would have taken if they've got these
alien balls why do they even need to
make the weapons and sell them they
could just enter vaults or whatever they
wanted to and steal all the money they
need it may be set for life they went to
this much trouble with security and got
or built a being invisible jet but
didn't put any locking mechanisms on the
actual crates themselves just a demo I'm
going
on the outside of an invisible jet fine
if I go first - cute line but she is not
your girlfriend she only went out with
you once to a dance were you immediately
abandoned her sony made a movie and
Marvel said hey let us edit that fight
scene for you in our signature style and
Sony said no way but Marvel did it
anyway
good thing no one was hanging out on
Coney Island on this night the Spider
Man also resistant to fire sometime
between the ferry and the plane and now
this he should just be ash at this point
but my friends call me MJ what you movie
I thought you don't have any friends
and why do you now exactly you've done
nothing but flip people off and make
mean drawings of them this entire movie
so what happened to change all this and
I'll introduce the world
the newest official member of the
Avengers why would Tony go from I need
the suit back - you're part of the
Avengers after one heroic moment for
Peter
he took the suit for Peter going after
the vulture and then when Peter goes
after vulture again boom welcome to the
club he's still a 15 year old kid
where's the kid he'll ask peppers here -
this really does feel more and more like
Iron Man for haha they tricked you
Robert Downey jr. I know you said you
didn't want to do a fourth but they
pricked your ass Peter really needs to
learn how to close and lock a door
patience the movies final end credits
scene is a big old Feud everyone that
stayed to watch something at least a
smooth more entertaining than a troll
this place is horrible smells like bald
I'm Batman
hey shoot ladies yes I feel bad calling
you soup lady should probably give you a
name Samantha a Blizz no no no what
about Carrie Samantha either
Don't Tell hurry
[Music]
[Applause]
the world's changing it's time we change
too
you either die a hero or you live long
enough to see yourself become the
villain
[Music]